those on the medical front line in
paraguay have been warning for some time
that the health system was buckling
under the strain
nearly 200 000 people infected with the
covet 19 virus
and 3 700 dead
the health system is currently saturated
on the verge of collapse
we're fighting to safeguard the
integrity and the life of our
compatriots
all 655 icu beds serving a country of
seven million
and now full sotu are many other beds
and the country's military has offered
its facilities
also supplies are running low
we've got supplies but not enough to
treat the number of patients we're
receiving right now
we've got more than 120 and more are
coming it's very intense
demonstrators earlier this month were
tested across paraguay
accusing the authorities of corruption
and mismanagement
in their handling of the pandemic
these vaccines arrived as part of the
kovac scheme to supply poorer countries
but critics say it's not enough
there's a similar picture across latin
america this
third batch of the sinovac vaccine sent
by china to colombia
came with this message from the chinese
president xi jinping
he said the vast pacific ocean can't
stand in the way of the profound
friendship between the peoples of china
and colombia and that in the face of the
covet-19 outbreak
the two countries have been working in
solidarity and anti-pandemic cooperation
but most ordinary people are still
waiting peru has passed the grim
milestone
of 50 000 dead there are no respirators
there's no icu beds there's nothing
so we have to wait for the patient to
die and doctors tell us this from the
inside of the hospital
when we are out here
meanwhile in brazil hospitals are also
reaching capacity
nearly 12 million people infected 293
000 dead residents are being urged to
stay indoors to stay away from crowds
with even the famous beaches of rio de
janeiro closed to visitors
daniel schwein al-jazeera buenos aires